this order
by president putin came shortly after
the announcement
was made about two delegations ready to
meet
and we see this announcement this order
as an attempt to raise stakes and to put
additional pressure on the ukrainian
delegation
but we will not give in to this pressure
if the order of president putin
to put on high alert his nuclear weapons
is a direct threat
to use
these nuclear weapons against ukraine
then i have a very simple message
it will be
a catastrophe for the world
but it will not break us down
we will not surrender
we will not capitulate
we will not
give up a single inch of our territory
this afternoon putin has announced
that he is putting russian
nuclear deterrent forces
on high
alert
it's important to stress that
the nuclear forces of russia has been
put on high alert
i will today propose to use the european
peace facility for two emergency
assistance measures
to finance the supply of lethal material
to the ukrainian army
as well as originally needed fuel
protective equipment and medical
supplies
another taboo
has falled
the taboo that the european union was
not providing arms in a war
yes
we are doing because this wall requires
our engagement in order to support the
ukrainian army let me take that question
in two parts first let me address the
second part of your question relating to
nuclear
i would like to take this opportunity to
denounce the bellicose and irresponsible
rhetoric
of mr putin
canada stands united with allies in base
of his naked aggression
and
the
rhetoric relating to
nuclear
capability that we heard this morning
is highly irresponsible
and we denounce it wholeheartedly i
think that's a distraction from the
reality of what's going on in ukraine
this is a an innocent people who are
facing a
totally unprovoked act of aggression
against them
and what's actually happening is that
they are fighting back perhaps with uh
more effect
with more resistance than the kremlin
had bargained for and i think that is
what is really going on you can see some
of the logistical difficulties that the
russian forces are experiencing you can
see and i think the the russian defense
ministry have themselves conceded that
they're having casualties this is a
disastrous misbegotten
venture by president putin it can lead
to no good whatever for russia as we uh
in the west have said
continuously from the beginning it needs
to end if he has a proposal to negotiate
and withdraw then all the better